bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors on va commencer par
ses propos de matteo salvini c'est ce
qui l'a twitté un tout à l'heure je vais
le site et le procès voulu par la gauche
et les fans de l'immigration illégale
commence combien cela va-t-il coûter aux
citoyens italiens quelle lecture faites
vous de ces propos
c'est vrai que c'est un problème qui est
beaucoup plus vaste justement et c'est
très intéressant ce procédé très
intéressant non pas seulement par
rapport à matteo salvini mais par tout
le système d'accueil qu'il peut y avoir
des migrants matteo salvini a défendu
une ligne qu'il a tenu jusqu'au bout ce
sera justement intéressant durant ce
procès de comparer certains autres
membres du gouvernement à ce moment là
les deux autres ministres qui avait
signé avec matteo salvini au début avant
finalement de rebrousser chemin
l'ancien président du conseil monsieur
comté qui a appelé aujourd'hui à
témoigner mais également par exemple le
l'ambassadeur italien à l'union
européenne qui lui aussi va témoigner
aujourd'hui et parler des difficultés
qu'il a pu avoir également avec
bruxelles pour replacer ensuite ces
migrants c'est tout le système
aujourd'hui c'est pas seulement matteo
salvini qui va passer sous procès c'est
tout le système d'intégration et
d'arrivée des livres qui vivent
aujourd'hui sous procès oui comme on y
vient conter
est appelé à témoigner parce que matteo
salvini l'adie n'a pas agi seul ce à sa
demande a été validé par le gouvernement
de l'époque et par monsieur comptait ce
procès va peut-être permettre d'établir
des responsabilités clair dans cette
histoire
oui tout à fait c'est la grande question
qui sera le responsable ce qui est
certain c'est que matteo salvini a
toujours signé le blocage s'est tassée
sur d'autres ministres monsieur
toninelli madame trenta avait signé
aussi en premier cours au deuxième nom
puisque entre temps il ya eu le tribunal
de la grille jantes qui est responsable
de l'île de lampedusa qui avait demandé
expressément de faire rentrer ces
migrants pour des problèmes sanitaires
et des personnes malades sur le bateau
de l'autre côté monsieur condé se défend
en disant que lui justement avec
l'ambassadeur de l'italie à l'union
européenne il était en train de négocier
avec les autres pays pour l'accueil
chacun se renvoie un peu la balle
aujourd'hui personne n'est vraiment
responsable à les écouter justement ce
procès va être très intéressant pour
savoir quelle est la ligne directrice
qu'il faut conserver quelle est la ligne
directrice qui sera appliquée pour la
suite ça va être une jurisprudence
nourrit alors salut mini assure avoir
agi pour le bien de l'italie il avait
des soutiens à l'époque en at-il encore
autant
la situation a largement changé et à
cette époque il y avait aussi une
situation de crise migratoire bien
différent 2019 et une année où il ya
énormément d'arriver en italie un peut
être l'année la plus forte qu'il y ait
eu les dernières années c'était a été
beaucoup moins fort actuellement nous
rentrons la période de l'hiver la mérite
beaucoup plus agitée il n'ya plus
d'arrivée de migrants donc on va dire
que ce débat va être ouvert au niveau
international mais en italie on en parle
finalement relativement peu parce que ce
procès va de toute façon être très très
long et puis matteo salvini a perdu pour
d'autres choses d'autres affaires et il
a perdu principalement car sa principale
concurrente
giorgia meloni a vraiment pris le pas
par rapport à lui au niveau de la droite
et de l'extrême droite italienne à moins
de moins en moins d'espacé aux cinq
minutes perd du terrain un peu tous les
jours par rapport à des histoires qu'il
peut avoir justement cette crise
migratoire qui semble un peu maintenant
une redite d'autres histoires qu'ils à
l'intérieur de son parti la ligue qui a
quelques tombes aux affaires de divers
bords et puis également donc aujourd'hui
la situation en général la nouvelle
dynamique de la droite italienne vers
giorgia meloni alors vous êtes assure
psa en italie justement
comment et est ce que les italiens
attendent beaucoup de ce procès
ce sera très intéressant de voir je
pense qu'il ya une attente des italiens
et des siciliens tout particulièrement
parce que c'est vraiment un problème à
plusieurs étages le premier étage c'est
la sicile les migrants arrivent en
sicile est généralement aucune autre
région italienne ne veut les accueillir
donc la sicile doit prendre à sa charge
tout le flux de migrants qui arrivent la
sicile étant déjà une île qui a ses
difficultés et ses problématiques
sociales ajouté en plus sa crise
migratoire ça ne l'aide pas les
siciliens ton une réponse ensuite les
italiens attendent aussi une réponse par
rapport à ce qui devait être la
répartition des migrants on voit très
bien qu'il ya de très très grande
difficulté après faire distribuer on va
dire faire un la répartition de ces
migrants dans les autres pays de l'union
européenne et l'italie et la sicile
encore plus ce sont parfois un peu
abandonné par rapport à cette situation
où il accueille quasiment toute la crise
migratoire mais qui finalement n'ont
aucun soutien après deux avertis de
bruxelles c'est aussi là que ça va jouer
les italiens attendent je pense une
réponse de bruxelles aujourd'hui aussi
de savoir lors des prochaines été lors
des prochaines crises migratoires qui
répondra aussi qui ne laissera plus
l'italie seul fabien gilot merci à bout
je rappelle que vous êtes enseignant à
l'université de turin en italie merci
d'avoir été en direct sur arte france